good afternoon everyone welcome to the
penultimate session for the day in this
talk will focus on security by default
nan tous I don't have a demo so I can't
really blame the Wi-Fi if something goes
wrong let's see how it goes so I am Arun
Kumar I go by a K I'm a technical
program manager with Google cloud
specifically for gke container and Antle
security for agenda for this talk will
start at what are the driving philosophy
and principles behind Antho security
then we'll dig deeper then we'll dig
deeper on some of these security
features we'll then move on to
discussing some best practices from a
security perspective for anthos we will
finally talk about shared responsibility
and how secure the responsibility for
securing that cloud Saddles between the
provider and the user time permitting
finally we'll have a Q&A let's jump
right in what are the philosophy that
drives the security work behind anthos
so we wanted security by default to be
the underlying theme users should not
have to become security experts
themselves in their quest to modernize
their apps our users have sophisticated
pretty advanced and enterprise gate
compromised systems most of these are
for valid business reasons complaints
and regulations being among the chief of
them we want to meet customers where
they are the best of our security
capabilities to be able to integrate
seamlessly with your existing
infrastructure finally at Google and
Google cloud we take security very
seriously we want our users to benefit
from our security culture which has been
battle tested and simple over the years
we also have a strong presence in Sagat
and kubernetes products security
committee
we started by writing a security white
paper for anthos very maybe I didn't
maybe identify and talk about major
security challenges that users face as
they migrate from traditional to modern
apps the first among them is about
enforcing consistent policies across
environments this could be across nodes
across clusters even across multiple
clouds antle's helps you solve this
problem with ECM moving on to the second
major challenge it's a question of how
does how can you effectively secure your
software supply chain in your
organization and only deploy trusted
workloads the last one talks about
securing multi-tenant environments
across a shot platform two and three
will address shortly in our talk I also
urge you to take a look at our anthro
security white paper it makes for an
interesting reading moving on
so our capabilities are organized across
these five core security design
principles that we have the first of
them is infrastructure security then
supply chain security and runtime
security the fourth one is configuration
and policies
the last one is compliance and
certifications we will only talk about
the first three in this talk we already
discussed configuration and policies in
the ACM talk in detail in the morning
complaints and certifications that's a
whole big topic unto themselves and they
desire more than they require more than
half an hour by themselves moving on
let's start with a future deep dive and
with infrastructure and network security
so workload identity which is in beta
addresses the problem of how you can
access GCP services from within your
kubernetes and GK workloads earlier
users face an impossible trade-off
between security and usability if you
wanted to access seamlessly GCP services
and resources you either had to forgo
principles of least privilege or you had
to deal with burdensome config rotating
credentials and so on so whose workload
identity we built a completely new
I am primitive called identity
namespaces so what it does is it takes
your kubernetes service account identity
and binds it with a google cloud service
account identity and once that happens
workloads only have minimal and required
permissions and Google takes care of
managing all the credentials ready to
discharge on our side moving on node
Auto operate this future helps keeps
your nodes up to date with the most
recent and the stable version of
kubernetes this is particularly
important in the context of security
patches right so if there is a security
patch that has been released
jika automatically patches all your
notes for you this is available for both
costs and open to you can also schedule
a maintenance window to kind of define
when you want these upgrades to happen
shielded DK nodes this protects your the
node bootstrapping process by anchoring
with a VT p.m. a TPM is a specialized
chip that holds the encryption keys in
your machine a V TPM does the same thing
for a virtual machine when you use this
feature your secrets and your
credentials are isolated and protected
in this VT PM exfiltration becomes super
difficult a node identity is always
verified to the cluster so arbitrary
nodes and steal credentials and then
enroll with them by themselves at the
cluster
application-layer secrets encryption we
are launching this in GA I think last
week please try it out with this feature
what you do is you take your secrets and
credentials you encrypt them locally on
H CD with a data encryption key or a
deck this jack is then encrypted by a
key encryption key which you manage and
store in cloud kms cloud KMS or cloud
key Management Service manages these
keys for you and also access a root of
trust upon which you can hold all your
credentials I have a mandatory call out
to make sure so by default kubernetes
secrets are plaintext
they are not encrypted right what GK
does for you is always and automatically
by default encrypt all your secrets all
of them are stored encrypted in disks
and GK also kind of monitors access for
them and so on
this feature is just an additional level
of control that we provide you for
encryption mostly for regulatory
requirements and if you have sensitive
workloads that you want to kind of hold
potentials to revoke and rotate and so
on horrible call out we also have
similar encryption mechanisms where you
can encrypt purses and discs along with
keys that you manage and you store in
cloud kms let's talk about a couple of
networking security features so network
policy is a native kubernetes feature
right most of you would be well aware of
it what does that says it helps you
manage pottekkatt traffic by default any
part is visible to all parts within the
cluster the IPS are public within the
cluster so this this feature helps you
restrict waterpot traffic let's move on
to VPC service controls do you want me
to go a little bit slower or is the
pacing right I'll take that if NS thank
you so this is one of my most favorite
features
VPC
servus controls enables you to configure
security perimeters around it around
your GCP projects and resources right so
you control the movement of data both in
and out of your projects when the comm
lines are secured data infiltration
you're protected against data
exfiltration from your projects all data
and resource accesses across boundaries
are also secured if you if your workload
span hybrid environments for example
buddy not you can use private Google
access along with my PC service controls
to draw a perimeter around your both
around your hybrid environments moving
on
so this slide actually represents a time
line of the of the GK security teams
efforts towards hardening the GK product
itself right over the years so as you
can see it started from July 2017 and we
have until like 1.15 interestingly as a
couple of dead bits if you see right so
if you see 1 & 2 so these are actual
vulnerabilities but the demonstrated
exploits that we secured in time so this
represents a gke hardening timeline it's
fair to expect that our that efforts
towards hardening our on-premise
solutions will follow a similar
trajectory and pattern the blue dots
represent future launches that we did
over the course of time that we are also
talking about in this talk the green
dots are implement our implementations
of default settings that we've done to
reflect best practices that we've
advocated in our hardening guides and
blocks and so on so these are available
to you by default I'll just pause a few
seconds if you want to absorb the slide
and then I'll move forward
okay how do you secure your software
supply chain this is from code build
code build test package deploy and so on
you start by using managed base images
Google builds and maintains these base
images and scans them for
vulnerabilities and automatically
patches them so if you if you use this
this is available on GCP marketplace -
any DCP customer it kind of all sorts
the responsibility of using cached
images away from you to Google this is
battle-tested used by Google we actually
use it for App Engine and our own
internal products vulnerability scanning
container in container analysis is the
official name this is a feature that
scans all your images in your private
google container registry for any known
CDE
right a common vulnerabilities or
exposures from the public databases this
works for Debian Ubuntu an alkine images
once you use official the data that the
report that you get from container
analysis you can either use it
internally if you have questions by
yourself you can kind of add metadata to
the images that your internal teams use
but most importantly this lets you
prevent those unpatched images from
being deployed using binary
authorization this is a super important
future what it does is it lets you as an
organization define deployment policies
and it codifies the deployment policies
for an entire organization you can
define custom requirements as signatures
or attestation x' or you can whitelist
repositories from which you want images
to be deployed so unauthorized images
images that either have a vulnerability
that are there are too old to be valid
that then kind of match up with the
attestation they are blocked from being
deployed to in your current solutions at
the kubernetes at a gke control plane
use an
admission controller for that at each
stage of your CI CD pipeline in Google
these attestations are checked and
Rihanna dated let's move on to run time
security so jiggy is hanboks this is a
very important feature if you run
sensitive workloads or if you have
workloads have varying levels of risk
profiles right earlier historically the
way you isolate let's say sensitive
workloads from net sales changing or a
developer or testing workload in your
organization as either to have this
either to stand up new VMs or in worst
cases even to kind of create new
clusters to isolate your workloads right
with GK sandbox you can achieve
isolation on the same node you can have
multiple ports at varying levels of
sensitivity and risks running on the
same part a red sari running on the same
node the isolation is at kernel level
and at runtime a plug in there my
co-workers Tim all clear a castle they
are giving a deeper talk on isolation
container escapes and sandbox overall
tomorrow so if you're interested please
go ahead great stuff for the talk
finally a brief call out for cloud
security command center this is the
central place on Google cloud platform
where you can unify analyze and view all
the security data for your organization
we we are also integrated with five of
the security partners so if you use any
few use any of these five partners to
augment your security capabilities all
of your tools are completely integrated
with CSEC
and the data is surfaced to see sec
surrounding up Anto security
capabilities we we went over
infrastructure security in detail
suppression at runtime we didn't get a
lot of time to focus on network security
I highly urge you to kind of when look
at the documentation every detail
horrible mentioned cloud armor provides
from dust ax steel sort of security if
you already had a steel in the morning I
AP I'll talk about it briefly must
master authorized networks let's you
accept only two traffic from whitelisted
eyepiece I put it up for a few seconds
and then move on if you want to absorb
it in let's move on to best practices
the first one centralized slogging right
we recommend that you follow the single
pane of glass architecture wherever
practical right of course if you have
sensitive data if you will have
auditable data that you want lock
separately you're always going to
subrogate it but use it having all your
monitoring and logging data centralized
is of immense value in the case of a
safar security foreign six or even as a
way for you to analyze and consume your
data anthos is well integrated with
google stackdriver
that you can use as a single pane of
glass star Trevor also integrates all
the Prometheus and fluently if you're
already using them the second best
practice is about protecting endpoints
this of course
deserves a separate talk by itself but
the TLDR
I would say is we would recommend using
cloud IEP or Internet aware proxy that
enables a more contact context aware
evaluation of users identity or
authentication we also recommend using
Apogee for API management if you're
operating at that scale three and four
we already discussed three is about
enforcing Network parameter boundaries
there's a super critical especially as
your workload span like multiple clouds
or between clouds and hybrid enforcing
policies and constraint consistently we
primarily do it using a cm of honorable
mention spot security policies if you
are a hardcore kubernetes user
be well aware of port security policy it
lets you define the next level and like
very low level security policies for for
authorization we also support gatekeeper
and OPA policies their policy controller
via ECM that leads you kind of custom
create constraints that you want to
reflect your business processes the last
one is about isolating workloads in a
multi-tenant environment so anthos
offers futures at multiple levels and
layers of isolation five of them are
here so if you use GAE private clusters
it gives you private eye piece right
your cluster is hidden from the internet
access to master is restricted Jiki
namespace is a native kubernetes concept
again
it lets you slice and dice your cluster
to reflect your use cases right you can
you can create a namespace for app per
user per team uh per sub organization in
your company and so on network policies
we briefly touched upon before but it
essentially that the suit of network
policy supported offer you fine-grained
layer 3 and layer for network level
access ASM or anthos service mesh on the
other hand provides you service level
access or at an l7 layer finally we
touched upon GK sandbox which offers you
protection at runtime so let's move on
to the final section shared
responsibility model so security in the
cloud is a shared responsibility between
the cloud provider and you are the
customer or the user right broadly
speaking as they move up the stack from
infrastructure-as-a-service
up to pass and then to SAS the
responsibility owned by the cloud
provider increases dramatically right
and things become easier for you to
manage and your responsibility decreases
as you go up the stack so specifically
speaking if you are using the
infrastructure as a service some
cloud provider the provider is
responsible for securing the hardware
the the physical machines the storage
attached to it as well as the network
through which you communicate right as
you move up to pass you get more things
out of the box right
the provider might most likely give you
an identity with a full-blown identity
system you will get data and access
management tooling you will have Orton
and odd C constructs natively supported
and a few more features like that right
if you move further up towards the SAS
layer it's a really cool operating
system there right like most of the
stuff by default has managed for you so
the provider manages deployment even
application security scalability
reliability uptime load balancing the
whole suit of them so G key or
kubernetes as you might assume falls in
the past layer right so what what what
Google owns and is responsible for is a
GK master right the master is completely
managed for you so it is hardened it is
secured is protected and it is upgraded
by GK transparently and completely
invisibly to you you are responsible a
for maintaining the nodes that you run
the worker nodes where you have deployed
your workloads right but even here if
you use banished base images that feed
on you to a few slides back and if you
open for auto upgrade even this is
completely offloaded to Google right
Google takes care of maintaining this
note for you it's completely out of your
hands
so what you are essentially left with in
GAE is a responsibility for securing
your application your application your
dependencies and whatever configuration
you have and if you change any of the
default config configured settings and
then you're responsible for securing the
new surface that this updated configure
open up so that's about GK on GCP shared
responsibility when you move to on Prem
and this is applicable for certain other
components of
those also as you can see the shared
responsibility model changes
dramatically right
you as a user are responsible for a lot
of stuff so while this means that you
have a lot to contend with in terms of
management this also means that you have
more control and more visibility over
how you want to define your workloads so
depending on your compliance and your
regulations and your existing business
infrastructure I think some of these
pieces and move and change but this is
broadly true
you